[Music]
[Music]
all right everybody let's go ahead and
start to shut up now
let's go ahead and uh start to settle
into your seats and uh begin shutting
your mouths
all right so
my name is
my name is jack griffin
and i don't want to be here
i am an award-winning philosophy scholar
who for reasons i won't go into finds
himself with a free year so i'm living
in my dead mom's apartment here in
toledo while killing a little bit of
time teaching
advanced placement biology
but here's the deal
i do not care about biology we're not
gonna do any biology in here and to be
perfectly clear this won't be one of
those things where over the course of a
year i secretly teach it to you
this also won't be one of those things
where i end up learning more from you
than you do for me
i know more than all of you combined so
that doesn't make any sense
i'm gonna spend the majority of my time
mentally breaking my nemesis with the
ultimate goal of taking his job as the
head of stanford philosophy and then i'm
gonna have sex with as many women as i
possibly can throughout the entire state
of california
but
you don't need to concern yourselves
with that
uh see
i might be forgetting something
mentally breaking my nemesis sex with
everyone in california no that was it
[Music]
welcome to ap bio
absolutely garbage
put them down
look i realize you guys are all nerds
and you want good gpas right is that
what's going on here
i'll make you a deal if you tell anybody
i'm not teaching you biology you get an
f if you keep your mouth shut you get an
a plus
look at it this way you guys are all
tired teens
this is gonna be your opportunity to
take a nap and if you're not tired
pop an advil pm
you will be out trust me
what are you doing come on put your hand
down i'm serious you're months away from
being an adult you need to start acting
like one just
talk
my name is sarika sarkar and i speak on
behalf of the entire student body when i
express our extreme displeasure in you
not teaching us biology can you say it
again
i believe i speak on behalf of no no no
not that junk
your name
oh sarika is her car
that's a great name
i love the philosopher prabhat sarkar
the entire universe exists within the
cosmic mind
what are you guys doing
don't write that down that's not me
teaching you stuff
who's this prince of darkness
this your book
yeah
so
mr griffin
i think you're in trouble
could we uh
can i talk to you out here for a second
uh-huh
[Music]
i get a new chair
a new oh well i don't know if that's in
our budget all right forget it okay i
got it what's up
what's up um
is it laundry day or
what's that supposed to mean man i
probably forgot to tell you we
sort of have a bit of a dress code here
so ralph i want to wear sweatpants you
want to say that your school's got a
former harvard professor teaching at it
right looks good for your school right
okay please i wasn't trying to be
aggressive here right but what you said
to me right now it
sucked
you know the worst part is i was
starting to like you man you know like
in a buds who get drinks once a week
kind of a way well that's that's us we
could still do that
[Music]
you know what i think you're just
blowing this thing out of proportion
yeah because i'm a laid-back principal
you know they make me wear this suit i
don't want to dress this sharp every day
but i have to because i'm an authority
figure but i'm still laid back and
you're going to see that
you know what
let's forget the whole thing come here
all right
that's my guy do you still want to get
that beer tonight no no no no see i
try to make a plan to bang my high
school acts as hard as i can you know
what i'm saying use our hallway voice
i'm trying to set that up all right okay
all right
you wrecked the sign that's why i came
here to
it's too late ralph it's too late
uh let's see a hall pass
well you were holding it okay
you